we're going to assemble our lovely
plural videos Christmas tree in the
foyer and then hopefully make it look
more Christmassy with some special
decorations
[Music]
oh my goodness what is that it's
adrenaline small molecule so if you get
all scared and stuff then your buddy
releases it and then get your fire flat
response
I've got angelic acid which is actually
a defense mechanism for beetles but I
just like the name of it what do you got
cyclic arsenic compound commonly
referred to as I think it had to
be done and I'm glad it happened
[Music]
so this is carbon here these are
hydrogens we have around the outside and
this is nicely this is carbon dioxide
co2 this is the contributed a climate
change
this is amino acid and this amino acid
really my favorite molecule because I it
is you know component part of protein I
just made a couple actor which is the
precursor of nylon 6 which is used in
the daily life like in the water water
so it is important so the molecule I
wanted to make today was cyclopropane
because it's a molecule I made in my PhD
but sadly we didn't have the right one
sort of sizes for the Molly mod so I've
made propane now Sam wanted to know why
I made propane particularly this model
molecule of propane it's because if you
consider the come formers that you can
sort of achieve with the molecule by
rotating around the double bonds if you
use your imagination it looks like a dog
I think I'll call him Leni okay this is
that trinitrotoluene or TNT sir Acme's
favorite I thought it had to be done I
have made glucose why do I love glucose
and yeah I'm pleased not sweet enough so
there you go I've got fear for which is
a compound that you can make from waste
oat material or Rand rice husks by
treating it with acid and says a fire
renewable compound and then I'm actually
using this in my research to see what
other compounds we can make from this so
looking at things that we can put into
fuels and alternative solvents and those
sorts of things
[Music]
it's a boron troy halite because we
hadn't got any born on the tree so we
definitely some boron on the tree for
Christmas I've made water which I think
is probably the single most important
molecule in the universe origin of life
that's displacing so I basically make
lysine because it's a very simple amino
acid I have made diamonds for the tree
and I made diamond because obviously
it's Christmas time girl's best friend
fingers crossed I'll get one chances are
awaited but can only dream so will none
of the molecules but oh good they don't
make the right shape and they don't look
Christmassy so I brought my own which is
much better has the right angles and you
can change its shape you see so this is
can either be sulfur tetrafluoride sf4
or it can be my favorite molecule and
tetra carbonyl which is very reactive
[Music]
I don't maintain I just like the shape
of it like the structure what is it
it's molecule of carbon or not and
hydrogen right so Adam and Adam on tape
Merry Christmas
I better go give them a lecture this is
Alpha piney so it's one of the smells of
pine trees so obviously if you've got a
pine tree here I thought we should have
a smell of pine trees so what we got is
this is a sort of six membered carbon
ring we've got a carbon carbon double
bond in there as well and it's a methyl
group here and two methyl groups off of
a maintance got this kind of bridgehead
carbon as well as what is called the
trade I will
[Music]
okay I've made that bit vitamin B 13
also known as erotic acid and simply
because it's called a rhotic acid I
thought it's got to be on that big
Christmas tree I have made GHB
[Music]
well it's pretty small but this is P
fork which is white phosphorus so I
thought I'd put the scale actually
because it illustrates a very
interesting point you see how all the
bends are really the bonds are really
bent that sort of shows you there's a
lot of ring strain in this molecule so
it should be really active and it really
is if you take white phosphorous out and
just throw it around liberally with
burst in flames immediately and that's
cause it's so reactive cuz these bonds
wind is so much strain they just want to
pop open that yeah and then be nice and
reactive what on earth is this monster
so this is a ligand we use in our work
and this is 2 2 by pyridine 4 for dynamo
and as you can see it's a bit of a beast
but the advantage of this particular
ligand and it's soluble in supercritical
co2 so we use in our work to use it for
reducing co2 down to more useful
products look there's even a little co2
molecule there as a solvent
well then business merry Christmas to
all of you Merry Christmas but this is
ammonia so nh3 quite an important
compound actually it's the basis for all
fertilizers generally speaking it's made
by a process called a harbor process way
to take hydrogen and nitrogen turn it
into nh3 right it's the wrong color
because that should be red really put
the red ones don't have enough air holes
but this would be Co
yes that's carbon oxygen for the triple
bond oh it's hydrogen or rocket fuel and
your Christmas off of the vine so what
we've got here is oxygen so that's owed
to it's got double bonds and it's what
keeps us all alive
[Music]
given a solution of hair bleach so what
we have here are some molecules of
hydrogen peroxide in amongst some water
so there we go we're going to put some
bleach in our tree well I've made
ibuprofen for two reasons firstly this
university owes quite a debt to this
molecule as it's a large part of the
Bhoots pharmaceutical company that gave
the University of campus and secondly
many hangover saved by this thing so
this is my Christmas molecule so got the
ethanol here so I think it's ripe that
will put the ethanol next to the
ibuprofen so that they can interact with
each other very happy also it's quite
symbolic because next year 2010 we're
going to start talking about molecules
so keep looking and very soon we're
going to launch molecular videos all
about molecules not just the elements
[Music]
you